I want to address something that we all
know is bullshit.
But we all see it anyway in order
to get some contrived
example
across
to whomever we're speaking with
about the power and flexibility
of adopting Kubernetes.
That the thing is the statement
Kubernetes
gives us X,
Y and Z
for free.
Usually we'll claim
that if you adopt enough Kubernetes
convention
that you will get scheduling
for free.
You will get
auto scaling,
service discovery,
centralized logging
for free.
And it's kind of true,
but there's a caveat, a catch,
something
that we often forget.
So for the sake of this video,
let's pretend that Kubernetes
is Florida.
Sure.
When you're in Florida,
you get sunshine for free.
When we're in Florida,
we have access to beaches
for free.
And of course when we're in Florida
for a small fee or investment,
we have access
to golf,
jet skiing,
nightclubs
and so forth.
And that all sounds amazing,
but you have to be in Florida.
And you know what isn't free?
Getting to Florida.
In order to get to Florida,
we have to plan it.
We have to convince our friends or family
that Florida is better than
California,
Sydney,
Tokyo.
And then we we need to pack.
We have to get to the airport.
We have to sit on a flight
that can take us one hour,
five hours,
fifteen hours.
All depends where you're coming from.
And then
we get there. We are in Florida.
We have access
to beautiful beaches and sunshine.
And of course,
even when we're in Florida,
it's not all plain sailing.
You're sitting there with your
margarita
by the beach enjoying the wonderful sunshine.
And you pick up a paper and you
read the headline.
Florida man uses host pad
for WordPress container.
So what's my point?
Kubernetes
is great and you get a lot of
things for free
after you paid the tax of adoption.
After
you've got to Kubernetes.
That journey is gonna be very different depending
on how much legacy you have and how
much you need
to migrate from traditional infrastructure to Kubernetes.
So
while there's a lot of pros,
there's definitely some cons too.
So with that being said, I'll wish you
the best of luck with whatever journey or
path you have ahead of you.
Please remember,
nothing is free.
Enjoy Kubernetes.